Russia is going to classify All Ships
traveling to Ukrainian ports as
potential carriers of military cargo in
a statement Russia's defense Ministry
said this is due to the termination of
the green deal Additionally the ministry
said all flag states of ships traveling
to Ukrainian ports will be considered
party to the conflict on kiev's side
parts of the Black Sea in the Northwest
and the southeast have been declared as
temporarily unsafe for navigation from
21 GMT on Wednesday
fighting's been intensifying on several
fronts in Ukraine for the second night
running dozens of Russian drones and
missiles have attacked Ukraine's main
Seaport Odessa Ukraine says buildings
and equipment for grain exports are
being targeted in Crimea a military
bases caught fire it's not clear what
caused the Blaze and Russian forces say
they've captured a railway station near
kopiansk the ukrainians say the Russians
are massing a hundred thousand soldiers
and around 900 tanks in the East well
we've got correspondence covering both
sides of the conflict in a moment we're
going to go to Rob McBride and key first
we're going to go to Julio Chapel valova
in Moscow Yulia let's talk about this
reclassification of shipping as far as
the Black Sea is concerned what has
Russia been saying
well actually the Kremlin used to say
many times in the past at that Kiev I
was using the green deal for smuggling
weapons into the country now the Russian
defense Ministry has issued the warning
for all International ships heading to
the ports of Ukraine and starting as you
said at midnight on July the 20th all
ships sailing in the Black Sea towards
Ukrainian pools will be considered
carriers of military cargo involved in
the Ukrainian conflict on the side of
Kiev and they mentioned several Maritime
areas in the Northwestern and
Northeastern parts of the international
waters of the Black Sea and they have
been declared temporarily dangerous for
navigation and earlier this week Russia
of course announced it was pulling out
of the green deal
meaning that Ukraine basically would be
uh while saying that there won't be any
safe passage for Ukraine ships and a
Ukraine called on turkey and the U.N to
continue transportations of the Grain
and as we know that over the past two
days Russia has been attacking the port
infrastructure in the city of Odessa
Julia I want to come back to you in just
a couple of minutes but I want to go to
Rob McBride first of all who's been
following developments from Kiev Rob
we've got more attacks then on Odessa in
and in with this latest announcement as
well that there's a reclassification of
shipping that's going to be going to
Ukrainian ports
that's right a second night of even more
intensive attacks centered on the porter
of Odessa seemingly in reprisal for
Monday's attack on the Kirch bridge that
connects with Crimea Russia vowed a
tough response at the time and this
would seem uh to be that Monday also saw
of course Russia pulling out of the
Black Sea grain deal and Ukraine is now
accusing Russia with these attacks on
Odessa which of course is a very
important grain exporting Hub of really
showing Russia's attitude towards Global
Food security
a night of intensive air attacks in and
around the port city of Odessa Ukraine
says grain handling facilities were the
target
Ukrainian commanders say dozens of
drones and missiles were launched by
Russia and while some were intercepted
many got through
images on social media showed damage to
Port facilities as well as buildings in
the city with reports of some civilian
casualties coming in the same week that
Russia pulled out of the Black Sea grain
deal which provided a safe shipping
Corridor for exporting Ukrainian grain
keeves says it shows moscow's disregard
for Global Food security
last night Russian Rockets targeted
Ukrainian Port infrastructure which is
involved in the export of food and
agrarian produce such attacks conducted
by Russia Target not only our country
but also global stability
this was the second night of air attacks
mainly targeting Southern Ukraine in
what appeared to be Russia's promised
reprisals for the attack on the Kirch
Bridge connecting the Crimean Peninsula
on Monday Ukraine says in addition to
damage to grain handling facilities
sixty thousand tons of food was
destroyed in Tuesday night's attack the
ukrainians are accusing Russia of trying
to create a global hunger crisis Rob
McBride Al Jazeera Keith well also today
the leader of the Wagner group has
apparently reappeared for the first time
since the mercenaries moved to Belarus
after their Mutiny in Russia
in a video that hasn't been
independently verified if Gainey
pagosian is reported to be heard telling
his Fighters that they wouldn't take
part in the war in Ukraine anymore and
that was happening in Ukraine is a
disgrace pregocians also told them it's
time to prepare for what he called A New
Journey to Africa let's go back to Yulia
she's still with us in Moscow the video
we've just been looking at there Juliet
very dark very difficult to see who is
actually in the picture it's very
difficult to identify pretty much
anything at all but it is going to give
rise to more speculation about where
you've got any progression is and how
safe he is
yeah exactly it's a very strange looking
video and we can't say where exactly it
was taped but according to sources
Evgeni progression was addressing his
fighters in a new field camp in Belarus
allegedly it was a flag transferring
ceremony uh when debugger company
flanked from the base in the village of
Mokena in Russia's southern krasnada
region was transferred to Belarus and
it's believed to be the first video with
pregosian released after the failed
military Rebellion that took place at
the end of June it was announced that
Wagner would stay in Belarus for some
time and then they would probably head
to Africa just several days ago we were
reporting that Wagner commanders had
already begun training belarussian
territorial defense units stationed in
military camps near the Belarusian city
of osipovichi but no one can say exactly
what tasks the Kremlin has prepared for
them how many Mercury trees have arrived
in Belarus how many of them will remain
in Russia who's going to finance them
there and earlier there were also
reports that the Wagner Fighters began
handing over their military kit to the
Russian Ministry of Defense so what the
Wagner group looks like now is a big ask
and according to analysts there is an
option that probably progression will be
removed from the group's management
Yulia thank you very much indeed there's
Julius bringing us up to date from
Moscow
or further eastern Ukraine battles are
intensifying as both sides try to break
through the front lines the ukrainians
say the Russians are amassing a hundred
thousand soldiers and 900 tanks Assad
bank has visited a bombed out town to
see how the few who've remained are
braving the threat of further attack
there's an eerie emptiness in seversk
the grass is overgrown straight animals
went to the streets
the buildings are burnt at shells of
what they were before the war thousands
of people used to live here few remain
this man tells us we receive aid but
every day they fire mortars I'm fed up
with it we hear the bang and four
seconds three seconds two seconds they
land despite the sounds of the shells
firing and Landing people gather to
enjoy what they can of the summer days
solution when the missiles hit we were
here where else would we be we saw the
two clouds rise from two locations
mushroom shape nobody was injured it was
just very powerful and everything shook
it's the little everyday things that
people hold on to here
I have a small gas stove and a small
canister that's how I heat the water I
put the coffee sugar and some special
spices cinnamon and has a good smell
soya says she doesn't want to leave
people go to other parts of Ukraine that
don't see the war they say you're from
dombas this all happened because of you
go back to donbass why don't you flee
elsewhere but where should we flee some
hostel I live in my own flat my own from
the edge of town you can see Lisa chansk
Russian forces took control of it in
July last year everything in between is
considered too dangerous to visit the
playground is empty There Are No
Children left and just like that the
afternoon peace is shattered gunfire can
be heard as Ukrainian soldiers attempt
to shoot down a drone when you visit
these towns and Villages along the front
line you ask yourself what's left of
these places yes they're a position on a
map and may hold some strategic
significance but most of the buildings
here have either been destroyed or
damaged and most people have left
bubbles
[Applause]
and and that gives you an idea of
what this place is going through there's
artillery strikes and there's drones up
in the air
[Music]
and we can't leave until there's a lull
in the battle
because we don't want to become a Target
I said Big Al Jazeera
eastern Ukraine
the fire is broken out at a military
base in the Russian Annex Crimea Russian
media is reporting explosions have been
heard at the base near Australia extreme
the Kremlin appointed governor of Crimea
says at least 2 000 people have left the
area the fire follows explosions on
Monday which damage the Kirch Bridge
which links the peninsula to Russia
the cause of the fire will be determined
by investigators there are no casualties
to date outside assistance to Crimea is
not needed the consequences of the fire
will be dealt with in the near future by
the interior Ministry forces the FSB and
so on people are getting all the help
they need I ask everyone to remain calm
and focus only on official sources of
information